Thanks so much guys.
I'll try and talk for about half an hour or 40 minutes or something,
uh,
about the origin of the project.
I'll give it a little bit of context and explain.
The first thing I suppose I need to kind of demystify is that very frequently
people assume that it's some kind of wish granting app where like miraculously
you're going to kind of make stuff happen.
The APP doesn't do that.
It takes one positive action everyday in the direction of travel in terms of
what it is that people have articulated.
But I'll specify that a little bit more.
And then as I say it,
talk about the history of the project,
where it came from,
exemplify some of the actions that the app takes and then talk a little bit
about what the conceivable future of it might look like.
And then as I say,
I hope at the end we'll have time for questions.
I've always had got a caveat this talk by saying that we've had a couple of
technical issues with regards to setting up the slides.
So if at some point,
uh,
the screen goes dark,
then you'll have to forgive me what I'm trying to remember how to reboot it.
So just a tiny bit about my background.
I've always worked in the kind of media sector,
so it mainly in television and uh,
for a brief spell for a couple of years at the radio station Kiss FM,
I've worked for a bunch of advertising agencies for Channel Four and also comedy
central,
the Viacom owned brand.
Uh,
and I about probably four years ago,
I just turned 40,
a classic midlife crisis,
started thinking and I've had this idea and I thought if I don't now do
something about putting it into the world and making it happen,
maybe it will never kind of manifest.
And there were three principal kind of creative influences that I had,
not necessarily things that I was utterly obsessed with,
but they're just things that are caught my attention and had maybe bought a book
or looked into them a little bit further.
The first of these was a,
uh,
a project called post secret.
I don't know whether anyone's heard of this,
but a guy in the states called Frank Warren,
not to be confused with the English boxing promoter,
ours people to hand make a postcard on which they articulated something that
they'd never told another living soul and to anonymously send it to him.
And he received literally hundreds of thousands of postcards.
This guy,
he's done six books now,
he does exhibitions,
speaking tours.
What started as a kind of a reasonably understated and scruffy tumbler blog
became this phenomenon,
and I was interested,
I suppose at the little snapshots that this gave into people's lives and there
was no backstory,
although though often it's possible to kind of imagine what it might have been
and he didn't really know what happened next,
but just this idea of a brief glimpse into someone's kind of soul with something
that I found really kind of engaging in terms of the authenticity of it,
I suppose super unpolished,
very authentic,
as I say,
and something which kind of resonated very frequently.
Kind of melancholic as well.
You know,
I smile all the time so that no one knows how sad and lonely I really am.
The type of stuff that in this increasingly kind of polished world of social
media,
we would be unlikely to post,
say on Instagram or something like that.
Something that felt like because of the anonymity,
people's identities weren't associated with it.
It felt like it was coming from a kind of truer place to me.
There was another thing that I really,
really did like,
and this,
I did buy all the books are called found magazine and this,
uh,
again was a kind of a pretty understated project started by a guy called Dave
Rothbart and he just produced a compendium of notes that either people sent him
or that he found and that was it.
And again,
it provides a similar kind of a little snapshot into people's lives.
And there was something super fascinating about it and they were simultaneously
disposable.
Literally,
they were trash that he found in the street.
But also I thought,
ah,
kind of potent and really interesting.
Uh,
call me dad died.
I thought that,
you know,
I wonder what's kind of going on there,
what's the nature of that relationship?
This one here,
I really like Mario.
I fucking hate you.
You said to me that you have worked and why is your car here at her place or a
fucking lie?
I hate you.
I fucking hate you,
amber pos page me later.
So,
so those kinds of things where as I say,
it's told you everything about someone and nothing about someone simultaneously.
And I was really into that.
Uh,
also,
and this is become a tiny bit of a kind of millennial cliche.
You could argue it has maybe 15 million followers on Facebook now.
This humans of New York project that you'll be familiar with,
photographer called Brandon Stanton,
just meeting people in New York and taking photos of them and hearing what it is
that they had to say about their lives in a paragraph or two.
And there's some extraordinary kind of wisdom contained therein.
There's,
there's some amazing pathos contained there in the,
some super inspiring stuff as well.
But again,
I guess what links these three projects to,
as I say,
I was kind of preoccupied with which they just provided this limited little
snapshot,
almost like a Polaroid,
as I say,
of someone's soul.
So I was thinking about this kind of concept for a while.
And then I was also looking,
I suppose without doing some wholesale like a,
you know,
competitive analysis of what the marketplace looked like.
I was seeing the kind of apps that were out there at the time.
There were a few anonymous ones,
whisper hub,
which is still quite a big deal at one called secret,
which has kind of segwayed into being something else.
Uh,
and another,
uh,
APP,
which was super popular for awhile on college campuses in the states called Yik
Yak,
all of which were anonymous apps,
which again,
allow people within your network to say something,
which they probably wouldn't say,
have they,
you know,
were they in a position to have to associate their own identity with it?
So I thought,
you know,
let's create an anonymous place where people can post the things they most want
in the world,
whatever those things may be.
And that was my initial iteration of the idea.
So I'm the,
uh,
reasonable devoted of the lean startup methodology and a lot of the Paul Graham
essays,
you know,
the a y Combinator founder,
uh,
and what I didn't do was to go out and try and raise VC capital or anything like
that.
I did it super scruffy,
low costs,
iteration of this primary idea and its sole function,
which just for people to articulate in a hundred characters or less,
as I say,
the things that they most wanted,
whatever those things may be.
And I kind of thought when I was like building it with the developer guy,
uh,
well maybe that'll just be like what it is,
you know.
But when I looked at it and we tried a little bit of a Beta test and I've got
some user feedback,
paradoxically something which was designed to be a little inspiring,
ended up feeling slightly kind of flat and listless because what was happening
was there were people,
as I say,
we're articulating their hopes,
dreams,
desires,
aspirations.
But if nothing was happening as a consequence,
it ended up feeling like a slightly deserted kind of Pinterest board where
people are like put this stuff.
But it just was a repository for half kind of forgotten dreams and 40
[inaudible] ambition,
you know?
So it ended up,
as I say,
feeling a little bit kind of tired and it's strangely a slightly depressing
place to hang out.
So the thing that I suppose catalyzed it,
and I wouldn't want to over exaggerate the extent of the arts success of the
project.
It's not like it's some snapchat style phenomena,
but the thing that people seem to kind of gravitate towards or that galvanized
it was this idea of taking meaningful real world action.
So I'm a,
I'm really very interested in technology but equivalent,
the interested as we all are,
I'm sure about the kinds of things that happen away from keyboard.
So I thought could you do an interesting thing?
And I was,
you know,
uh,
quite into these projects where the APP itself was like a nicely designed thing.
Take Airbnb for example,
that's a cool APP.
You could design it in loads of different ways.
Website looks nice,
uh,
endlessly kind of changed an iterated to try and perfect it.
But the amazing thing about airbnb was the fact that millions of people were
having these extraordinary weekends where they met someone who became a friend
in a foreign city.
That was really what the user experience was.
That was the real kind of Ui right there.
So I thought,
is there something cool that you could do to bring these aspirations a little
bit closer?
Not to miraculously,
like I said at the start of the presentation,
and as it says up here,
not granting wishes in the way that you might see in a kind of children's a
fairy story or a small seed Disney thing.
But just I suppose I'd hearing to the Credo that any action is better,
the nun,
is there something that we can do about each of these wishes that makes them a
three dimensional real thing,
a couple of steps closer to that professor aspiration rather than it just
hanging around on the Internet being like another tweet or something and that
was all the kind of thinking was so the site's actions are unique and freshly
created every day and they can be anything depending on the nature of the wish.
And you see like those three projects that I was talking about at the start you
see things which are happy or sad or melancholic are uplifting.
The interesting thing about it or one of the interesting things that I found
about it is that no two wishes are kind of alike and a wish,
which is super kind of sad and heartbreaking,
seems to sit quite happily alongside another which,
which might be as I say,
uplifting or euphoric in some way.
So there were only a few guidelines which people have been pretty good at
adhering to of the many thousands of wishlist.
There are on the site have probably had to delete lights six.
I think most of them were from the same person.
Uh,
and as it says here,
basically,
I don't know how well you can read that.
Don't be lame.
You know,
it's,
it's not that funny to kind of write,
oh I wish I could fly or whatever.
Don't be greedy.
So say I wish I had,
you know,
a free Rolex or whatever,
that's not going to get any traction.
And the way in which the site was working in terms of its Ui is that the wish
that was most up voted each day.
The wish that came to the top of the list,
the top of the chart as it were,
that was the one that was going to have some action taken against it.
Don't be a dick.
So any form of behavior that advocates kind of breaking the law or some kind of
racial hatred or something like that,
that was just going to get taken down.
Don't be gross to be too selfish,
et Cetera,
et cetera.
Ps,
we've heard the thing about unlimited wishes loads.
It's hilarious.
So people seem to kind of understand it self governed pretty well,
the site.
And if occasionally there is something weird on there,
some little typically email me and say,
oh you know,
you should check out this wish.
It looks a bit odd.
But as I said,
they were all completely anonymous,
a 100 characters or less.
And the wish that got to the top everyday at six o'clock,
that was the one that had action taken against it.
So let me give you some examples of the actions that the APP takes.
Uh,
so the quality of Trump's stuff at the moment for obvious reasons.
So I think the,
which was,
I wish that Donald Trump wasn't such a deck,
but I've had variants of that loads of times.
And then that's a thought that probably everyone has had.
What you get from this project is that I actually wrote a letter to him at the
Trump foundation where that he never wrote back to me.
I don't know why he's must be busy,
but it's just a kind of slightly Sarky why did you once tweet tiny children are
not horses?
Everyone knows that already.
What were you thinking when you said,
if a banker,
when my daughter,
perhaps I'd be dating her,
can you not see that's kind of gross,
et Cetera,
et cetera.
And that stuff in terms of growing the site goes over pretty well on Twitter
about when Twitter was still like a thing to dig at your competitor there.
Uh,
and so sometimes I'll do something in the spirit of the wish itself.
So that's clearly a tongue in cheek,
slightly ironic wish.
And so the response is equivalent,
um,
when people wished there's call of stuff about,
uh,
the elderly,
you know,
there's a phenomena in this country and to certain extent in the states where
there's an epidemic of loneliness amongst old people in this country.
And very frequently,
I forget what the statistic is,
but it's a high percentage of people who are surprisingly high.
Percentage of people will go like two weeks without having any form of human
interaction beyond the most prosaic one with the shopkeeper,
a postman or something.
So when people are wished for a treat for the elderly,
myself and my girlfriend,
thank you very much for helping me with that.
Visited an old people's home over the Easter weekend and festoon that with
hundreds of daffodils and chocolate eggs when people wish that their commute
wasn't so boring.
I changed the signage on the tube so it's very easy to download as I discovered
the London Underground type face and I just adjusted the signs to give people a
bit of a smile on their way to work.
So as I say,
it's one thing every day and I don't like go into a thing where I say,
right,
I'm going to do every tube chain or whatever.
It's what you're buying and inverted commerce,
although it's free,
what you're buying into is 24 hours worth of resourceful,
industrious,
hopefully creative kind of action.
But everything starts and ends within that 24 hour period.
I never say,
oh,
I'll get back to you in three weeks once I've got a thousand signatures or
something.
And this was a wish from a woman in Scotland who's daughter had been badly
bullied in secondary school.
So she came down to London and we arranged a really nice day out for her.
I use we in the royal sense.
I mean I arranged a day doubt for her and she went,
what does she do?
We met for breakfast and then she went to the royal ballet and had a kind of
backstage tour there.
She was really interested,
like a lot of teenagers are in a potential career in the performing arts.
So she met a ballet dancer and had a kind of back stage tour there and then the
ballet dancer gave her her love ballet shoes,
which was really sweet.
Then she went to pineapple dance studios and met with someone who had been a
backing dancer for like one direction and lots of people and it gave her a kind
of dance class.
Then she went to meet a friend of mine who I knew from my time at Kiss FM,
a WHO's a super nice,
very,
very sweet charismatic woman who uh,
is uh,
one of the DJ's.
She does the,
uh,
afternoon drive time kind of show.
And so she had a cup of coffee with her and talked to her about this experience
that she was having in school.
And then in the evening she went to a performance of Mama Mia and she wore all
black and like was sitting at the side of the stage with the stage manager and
saw how that kind of whole show was put together.
And a couple of those things where people that I knew already,
but a couple of those things where people,
and this happens quite a lot,
who were already on the site or four of those people who had been bullied
themselves when they were little and they said,
I see you've got this.
Which coming,
uh,
up about bullying?
Well,
I would be really happy.
I'm an actress now,
you know,
she should come down to Mamma Mia,
will this person at the Royal Opera House can help in this particular way with
the ballet,
et Cetera,
et cetera.
So very frequently I'll be coordinating something,
which the community itself is volunteering in terms of what it is that they
might like to do to help,
which is kind of Nice.
Um,
this was,
you remember that a while back where that Boko Haram,
the Islamic fundamentalist group in northern Nigeria kidnap those school girls,
some of whom have now been released.
Uh,
and so I went to the Nigerian embassy,
uh,
first thing in the morning before it opened and had written the night before,
the name of each of their missing girls on a post it note and then covered that
doors with that as a kind of gesture.
And very frequently,
as I say,
it is a gesture.
So I'm not claiming that as a consequence of me doing that.
The guards were miraculously recovered.
It's just an articulation of visualization,
a three d iteration of that which would otherwise just be a bit of social media
kind of Ephemera,
I suppose.
Um,
you know who I mean by Katie Hopkins.
It's like a female piers Morgan.
Someone wished that she would sign a gagging order.
And by a very strange coincidence,
I was reading a magazine and the week before this,
which came to the top and I saw that she was due to do a speaking event.
She was going to be in some debate about Brexit or something.
And so I went along to that debate and a folded over a piece of paper,
got her to sign the bottom here with her lame signature,
which adds to profess it,
little hearts.
And little did she know that clearly it wasn't legally binding,
it was just like a joke,
but she said,
ah,
you know,
in fact,
I'm sorry,
an embarrassed for pretty much everything I've ever done.
I'll go now that only works if you know who she is,
but she's a fairly reprehensible human being.
Uh,
very frequently they are about things,
social ills that we can see around us,
the wishes.
So if people wish for help for the homeless are just go out.
Again,
not miraculously claiming to rid the world of the,
uh,
you know,
problem that it has with homelessness,
but just,
you know,
visit half a dozen people,
take them some sleeping bags,
a cup of coffee sandwiches or lunch time,
whatever it may be.
Uh,
when people wish for more love in the world,
that quite often they're quite abstract things like that,
which as an expression of something or a nice sentiment,
but they're kind of woolly.
So I'll try and do something kind of crisp and specific with regards to it.
So,
uh,
on this occasion people wish for more love in the world and then distributed
flowers all over London.
And so people can take them back,
give them to their boyfriend,
girlfriend,
partner,
whatever,
tell them how much they loved them.
That was pretty popular.
There was this thing,
I wasn't aware of this phenomena,
but this is a very popular wish where people felt that when they went to an art
market department store,
Harrods or Selfridges or whatever,
they were frequently condescended to by people who worked on makeup counters.
I didn't know that that was a thing,
but apparently it was,
lots of people said,
oh yeah,
that happens to me the whole time.
So I put this sign in Harrods.
Customers should be advised that there may be subject to weathering looks and
occasional condescending comments,
which rust,
this will not detract from your shopping experience.
Uh,
this again was the community helping.
So this was a really sick boy in Florida who's just wanted to get a lot of
birthday cards and so crowd which members sent them to him.
Uh,
this was the thing.
Remember this is another arcane bit of tax law,
actually think it has been EU legislation rather than something that was maybe
under all kinds of ages in the UK.
But Feminine Hygiene Products were taxed as a luxury item,
which was obviously insane.
And there was quite a lot of stuff online about that.
So I sent this Tampon in this luxury packaging to the chancellor of the
exchequer with the sarcastic,
uh,
this was people wishing there was less bigotry of the world.
So I sent,
have you ever seen that website ship your enemies glitter?
It was like a big deal a couple of years ago,
you know,
cause glitter is a fucking nightmare,
isn't it?
If you open an envelope.
So I sent this I've uh,
EDL or something,
it was called like a horrible kind of,
you know,
far right extremist groups.
So I sent the leader of that.
I wanted to think of the kind of campus thing I could do.
So I had a vision whether or not there's manifest,
I don't know,
sometimes it would be nice to see to be there when this stuff happens,
but I had a vision of this guy getting covered in glitter and reading this,
sorry.
No,
No.
Um,
when someone wished for a half decent boyfriend,
I put up a kind of missing sign,
a presumed nonexistent,
uh,
just not a date basically.
And,
and again,
what happens with these things is you only need to put out one side or is it
actually put up more than that?
But I think I put up less than half a dozen signs and then someone sees it,
it takes a photo of it.
And by the end of the day,
I had a load of people getting in touch saying either I am that boyfriend.
So if you find someone,
then I am the candidate who ticks all this kind of criteria.
I have my own teeth,
positive bank balance,
et Cetera,
et cetera.
Uh,
awesome.
or a lot of people saying that if you do find this mythological man who I'm
convinced doesn't actually exist,
then let me know.
Cause I'd love to have dates,
but I would probably put together seven or eight couples.
And again,
I don't follow that narrative.
I just say,
look,
I'll introduce you guys.
Hope you have a good time.
Basically,
um,
when people wish that Jay,
this is not a political thing by the way,
but you know,
Jeremy Corbyn was getting quite little shit for looking scruffy and he did look
pretty bad.
I thought he did look kind of scruffy.
And David Cameron,
Denise say something to a PM qs about my mother would be ashamed of you or
something.
I can't remember what it was.
But anyway,
a friend of mine runs this,
uh,
company called Charles Tyrwhitt.
So I recall him,
Nick Wheeler,
he's called and said,
can you send me some smarter clothes?
And I swear that I've seen Jeremy Corbyn where this,
I swear I noticed that he didn't declare it because I thought,
how am I going to find out?
Cause the kind of guy that he is,
I just dropped it off at his kind of,
uh,
you know,
way does it.
Surgeries is an NP in his linkedin.
And I thought,
how am I going to know?
And because whatever you think about Corbyn,
the guy's got integrity.
I think he's got political integrity and integrity as a person.
And I thought,
I'm sure he's going to declare like working for the BBC or lots of institutions.
If someone gives you a presence above a certain value,
you've got to make a declaration about it,
right?
So that you're not susceptible to bribery,
particularly as an NP.
Um,
but I haven't seen him make a declaration about these shirts.
It well be that he just passed them on to his nearest charity shop.
Who knows?
But I,
I'm pretty positive that I've seen him wear that.
Um,
so like I say,
that's happened.
Something of that ilk.
Those are just a few quick examples.
And there are literally hundreds of others that's happened every 24 hours for
the last 1,136 days.
Uh,
people are really into it,
you know,
the Paul Graham guy and if you haven't read Paul Graham's essays,
uh,
about,
well about everything basically.
But the guy is super articulate and incredibly kind of perceptive.
But one of the things that he said in his,
uh,
he writes an essay about getting traction for whatever your new businesses
initially and how it is you find your first customers.
And he said,
and this really resonated with me,
you're much better off creating something that are a hundred people absolutely
love rather than a thousand people think is kind of okay.
And that other than that I thought was going to be my kind of guiding light with
this project.
That's what I'm going to do.
Find something that people are super into rather than the kind of slightly
ambivalent thing that occasionally I might dip in and out of.
And because there's a frequent,
what you'd call in TV world appointment to view slot cars every day at six
o'clock,
something new is getting published,
there's a reason to keep coming back.
Um,
so people's reactions have been amazing.
I would defy you actually without sounding too kind of self congratulatory and
annoying about it to find a website which has as positive,
uh,
feedback as this one does,
is great for press,
you know,
because you're always doing something or a invariably doing something which is
either a positive or mischievous and tonally like it was saying the
juxtaposition of things which is slightly kind of anti authority meets things
which are just kind of kind and positive,
you know,
existing in that space is good for social sharing.
Um,
and then,
yeah,
and now as a lucky percentage of you have,
I did a book deal about a year ago to write a book and basically what I've done
there is to take 99 of the most popular or wishes that just appealed to me.
So it's a selection of 99 of the thousand plus that the have been,
and it attempts to articulate in a reasonably kind of a lighthearted fashion how
it is that you can get a little bit closer to the aspirations that you might
have it.
So it's like a kind of self help book for people who would never read self help
books.
And as you said,
it started,
the conversation is designed to dip in and out of a classic book to have by the
bath basically.
Um,
and so other publishers around the world who have picked that up,
I don't know that everyone's going to do these 99 covers.
That was,
uh,
an idea that I had the,
I had never thought initially I thought,
let's do five covers because I was quite into,
as you know,
sometimes you'll see a magazine like vogue or published with five different
covers or Gq for their man of the year awards,
you know,
and,
and one will have tiny tempera and have Michael Caine or whatever.
And I thought that I must work quite well our new standard.
Otherwise,
they wouldn't do the incremental investment to do that.
I wonder whether that could work for display the bookshop.
And it does actually look nice in the,
uh,
when you see them all together.
This is at the publishing house.
This is something,
I took this photo the week before last,
when you see all 99 together,
this a common visual gratification and I guess this initiative and the fact that
these,
you know,
without again being too hot need about it,
these wishes a super kind of diverse and no two are alike.
That was the underlying point.
Uh,
and the designers did a brilliant job on that,
you know,
um,
the tone of it is designed as you'll see to be kind of lighthearted and
accessible.
So I wish I could ever do it.
We can.
I wish I knew a gentleman that they used to,
I wish I could find the best slice of pie in the world,
et Cetera,
which I have found the best lightweight in the world.
But that's another story.
Uh,
so it's,
it's not the,
it's not,
I hope anyway,
to kind of earn in that regard.
So those of you who've got a copy,
I really hope you enjoy reading it to post a review on Amazon,
if that is the case.
Um,
meanwhile,
so I'm thinking,
okay,
so we're going to do with this thing.
I've managed to make it kind of,
um,
not too expensive to run.
As I say,
I'm a massive disciple of the lean startup ideology.
So you will be surprised how little it has cost to do it.
But you can see from those examples that I gave you,
it doesn't cost that much to send a bunch of glitter to a far right leader,
for example.
They don't need to be enormous grandiose gestures,
these things.
But I was thinking,
okay,
so how am I going to make this like a commercial proposition?
And in a way,
is it kind of spoil the fact cause no one's ever been charged for anything.
Um,
is it going to kind of soya or somehow compromise it if it becomes something
which has got this commercial overlay on top of it?
So my solution to that,
such as it was,
I may well be proved completely wrong,
but this is my endeavor and I'll try and be successful in achieving it,
was to say,
okay,
so let's see if we can make it a kind of cross platform entity.
I've got to ideas around life events was a website.
There's an APP,
there's a book as I say,
which you have in front of you now.
And then I thought,
okay,
so let's see what we could do with a TV show.
Yeah.
Because wish fulfillment in TV terms,
it's been a huge kind of genre.
And if you can get it right then it's fantastic because it's heartwarming.
It appeals across a huge kind of demographic and particularly large commercial,
uh,
stations like ITV or really into programs where the whole family is gathered in
front of the screen rather than a singular demographic.
They don't really sell a singular demographic in the way that a news website
might.
They sell reach and they sell,
uh,
you know,
particular kind of profiles around adults with children,
et Cetera,
et cetera.
So if you can get it right then it's cool.
But I didn't want to do something which was so kind of vanilla or lowest common
denominator that it felt like it wasn't a adhering to the spirit of the project
today.
And so I got a little bit of cash from,
uh,
and network in the states actually.
And then I linked up with a guy called Ryan Ferguson,
who I only knew by reputation,
who runs as a slightly shadowy,
a collective of,
uh,
it's like an archaic kind of art collective of graffiti artists and civil
activists who exist as this kind of shadowy force who can be marshaled when
given an instruction from their leader.
I know that it makes it sound slightly kind of cult like,
but they do very cool things.
So I thought he'd be good to work with.
So he's based in,
uh,
Las Vegas.
So I flew out to la.
He came down from Las Vegas.
We had a little pot of cash that the network had given us.
And so,
uh,
I'll show you now the film that we shot,
which is like what they call a sizzle reel,
which you then take out to broadcasters and see whether or not they think there
might be potential in developing it further.
So you can see that,
like I say,
a kind of combination of things which are a random acts of kindness meet the
articulation I suppose.
And obviously I've realized that Donald Trump is like a super kind of lazy
target for anything satirical.
And I realized also that he was democratically elected,
but it is additionally the case that there's a overwhelming number of people who
are,
are pleased to see him lampooned.
And so,
uh,
as I say,
the site isn't miraculously claiming that they'll be able to remove him from
power.
You're just doing something to kind of visualize the wish that people have made.
Um,
so the ambition,
as I say,
wait,
I've gone too far,
uh,
is to have this brand that lives in every vertical or,
or a significant number of verticals so that a web presence APP exists already.
Ios App.
I haven't done an android app yet.
I'm sorry about that.
I should not,
uh,
the book,
which exists the TV,
which it depends who it is that one partner is with.
Like I say,
if you do it for ITV Margaret,
to do something slightly different to that,
which is going to be a little bit too edgy for them.
So it depends who your partner is.
There are a number of people who are,
uh,
you know,
if you were looking 10,
even five years ago,
you and he had a TV idea in the states,
you could either go to a network,
NBC,
CBS,
Fox,
et Cetera,
uh,
or you go to a cable operator to get your ideas away.
Now those people are still buying stuff or they're,
they're increasingly risk averse creatively,
but there's a new generation led by Netflix,
therefore,
obviously on demand players who are interested in innovative content and Amazon
have joined that fray now and putting significant budgets into originated,
both scripted and unscripted.
Uh,
and I think we'll see now a new wave,
uh,
of snapchat style people who are wanting to get into the content provision game.
And I noticed with interest this week that,
uh,
Facebook have developed a slingbox has style app that enables you to watch
Facebook videos,
videos,
obviously amazing for them.
They're putting strategically a whole lot of stuff around going live,
blah,
blah.
An APP that enables you to watch that stuff on your TV.
So this convergence that we've read about and heard about for so long of all the
screens coming together into a single entity,
that time is upon us.
The other aspect,
and I'm not like a crazy kind of data had kind of person,
but it is interesting to me and obviously one needs to use and harness that data
in a way which is respectful and appropriate.
But the idea that people volunteer information about the things they most want
in the world and then something meaningful happens as a result I think is a kind
of powerful one.
Uh,
you know,
one of the reasons he said staging the blind,
the obvious that Google is the extraordinary company that it is in terms of uh,
its cultural impact and in terms of it's a moneymaking abilities is that if I
put into Google as a search term,
flowers in Brighton or flights to Paris or the therapist in London or whatever
it may be,
that's a pretty strong indicator that I'm in demand for those things,
those people competing to bid on those key search terms.
Uh,
and so I wouldn't want to take this into a kind of territory whereby one was
aggressively exploiting that.
Not suggesting that you guys do that by the way,
but the,
the idea that I haven't fully developed this thought so you'll have to bear with
me as it is only partially formed,
but the idea of fleshing out and making a bit more human and a bit more rounded
and a bit more as we are as individuals.
Those kind of requests whereby your Prozac transactional requirements are have a
kind of counterbalance of things which are a bit more intrinsic in a bit more
kind of inner directed.
That feels interesting to me potentially.
And I think that we will see outside of search here,
let's just assume that you guys have nailed search,
which I think we can say that you kind of have,
but outside of that in terms of brand building stuff and search isn't always the
strongest way to build a brand and make a contribution to that.
But I think the most resonant brands in the future are going to be looking for
these cross platform solutions.
They're looking for meaningful data,
not anonymous reach.
And that was one of the reasons why our commercially,
for example,
a organization like the Guardian and massively kind of a deferential towards the
Guardian in terms of their editorial stance in the world.
But one of the issues that they have commercially is I think they went through a
period of thinking that reach and scale was going to be enough.
Oh,
we're in Australia now,
we're in the states now we've got this bureau,
blah,
blah.
Actually advertisers need something and want something slightly more
sophisticated than that.
And anonymous reaches increasingly quite a tricky thing to monetize.
You know,
they want meaningful insight.
Uh,
again stating the blandly obvious but engaging content,
not broadcast messages,
rich experiences,
not just conventional kinds of media.
And also I think particularly for the kind of generation x a a,
I don't mean this in like a some kind of quasi religious sense,
but being possessed of a higher purpose,
not a purely transactional thing.
What is it beyond enriching your small group of shareholders that your honor to
do?
What contribution is your brand making to the world?
I think that's super important kind of thing.
And finally,
you know,
we're all super adept to zoning out advertising messages.
If they do reach us,
we'd likely to be cynical about them.
But we've been trying as hard as we can to avoid them.
We have ad blockers,
popup blockers,
we have spam filters,
we have signs on our letterbox saying no junk mail.
We have PVRs that enable us to fast forward through the ads times 30 and so I
think increasingly I'm not one of those people says,
oh,
that game's over,
blah blah blah.
I don't think it is over a tool.
But what is the case is that it is irrefutable that if you are associated with
an action as a brand,
that is something which has taken place in,
happened in the real world.
And so if I was creating a kind of mini model in terms of how it is that brands
should engage with their consumers in the future,
I would say that do something meaningful to do something special that resonates
with people and their news media to shine a light on what it is that you've done
and encourage people to kind of share it.
And I think that if one gets that right,
that can be quite kind of powerful.
Um,
so like I said,
I don't know whether they still today people still talk about moon shots sooner.
You see that phrase moonshots in terms of,
uh,
something which feels like a,
a large idea that you probably won't necessarily be successful in achieving,
but nevertheless you don't let that prevent you from sending out on the
endeavor.
And I think here,
and this,
as I say,
I've done this completely on my own.
Occasionally.
My girlfriend helps me out intimately.
I have,
uh,
an intern,
but I kind of find that managing the interns basically easier just to kind of do
it myself.
So this is how far I've got on my own with no money,
no VC capital,
anything of that kind.
And fundamentally when you boil it down,
this is a place where anyone can share the things they most want in the world.
They can articulate those things and a meaningful outcome because as a result,
and that to me feels like,
you know,
a pretty big thought that I've only gone like I tiny,
tiny distance of scratching 1% of the,
of the surface or,
but that's my kind of like guiding star in terms of,
uh,
the core principle from which I will not kind of deviate.
And as I say it,
we're one to amplify that as an idea,
I think that conceivably is a huge,
uh,
a genuinely a huge thing.
Um,
so,
you know,
it's really not like a big deal this thing.
Uh,
and because I haven't quite worked out and monetize [inaudible] model,
I was in this slightly weird situation where you know,
normally everyone's super obsessed with getting users and we've got these growth
hacking techniques and there's entire industries that have grown up around how
it is that you acquire and hold onto users,
et Cetera,
et cetera.
This isn't like that because I didn't really know I was doing,
I just wanted to do something cool everyday and I know that sounds a bit
ridiculous,
but that is genuinely the activity that I've been engaged with.
But there are,
there were a load of wishes on the site now.
There are too many actually.
And one of the things that I,
one of the aspects of the experience doesn't work and I could do an entire
longer presentation about all the floors and this idea I hasten to add is that
if you put a wish on the site at the moment,
light layers of sedimentary rock,
you know,
you've got to kind of get through loads before it gets to the top.
It's not quite as tricky as one necessarily my thing,
but
that can be a bit demotivating.
I back to my original problem,
what I put that thing on there and then nothing happens.
No one agrees with me.
No one likes my wish that cause that's the kind of thing that can be
disproportionately depressing.
And so sometimes I wonder in this a family role disappearing photos age in which
we live,
maybe I should just reset the board every day at six o'clock and all the wishes
should vanish and then people remake them.
But maybe that itself would be like a laborious and demotivating experience to
have to that once again put it on that.
So there are loads of things still to kind of crack.
But currently if hypothetically speaking,
I stopped taking wishes today and just thought,
right,
I'll action or the wishes that you know are on the site currently,
it would take me over 30 years to get through all the ones that are currently
there,
which I'm got times there anyway,
I'm out of the 45 minute mark,
so I've slightly gone over.
Thank you very much for listening.
I really appreciate your time.
It's a great privilege to be here.
We've got a little bit of time for questions.
If anyone's got anything thing that they would like to ask me.
[inaudible]
hi.
Sorry Kevin.
A little bit late.
Have no idea what I'm talking about.
Oh,
what am I doing?
Uh,
no,
just,
you may have explained this at the beginning.
I was just wondering how you,
uh,
how are you funded or is it sort of self funded or [inaudible] it's a kind of
combination of things.
It's the kind of size now where does it say,
and this is a,
this is a true example that's an easy one to give you say the wishes.
Quite a lot of the wishing seem to relate to a low level of anxiety where people
are articulating the fact that their lives haven't quite turned out and the way
that they hope they might basically.
So say the wish was,
I wish I didn't feel sad,
anxious,
uh,
which I've had a bunch of times I could then as I've done reach out to,
um,
there's a little bronco rescue remedy.
Do you know that brand too?
Is it is,
it comes in a little per and you put a couple minutes,
it might be psychosomatic.
I've got no idea.
But it claims to what chills you out and uh,
stills an overactive mind.
Um,
so I can say to them and hearing I think lies something potentially,
again,
quite big because what advertising does historically is advertising vomits all
this stuff into the world and hopes that it mops up a few people who are in
market for what it is that it's got to offer.
Whereas what it is that I'm offering is a whole load of people who have self
electively raised their own hands to say,
I am feeling anxious.
So that's really valuable data.
So I can in my,
as I say,
low level way,
it is just me and my bedroom kind of thing.
I can say to people,
um,
I can say that due to,
you know,
rescue remedy,
I've got a lot of people here who have already told me that they feel anxious
and you came to make this great product.
Why don't you send a sample of your product to each of these people?
And if it's as good as you claim it,
as I'm sure you'll have some customers for life or if it kills their anxiety,
you probably wouldn't,
which you,
but you get the point.
Uh,
the,
the kind of the,
the fact is that it's really valuable to be able to have a conversation with a
brand and say,
I've got people who are in market for what it is that you do.
And so I've been able to do that,
which enables therefore the end user to get a good result.
I put this wish on a random website and now someone's actually sent me a
physical thing in the mail.
That's cool.
So that's a great result for that.
And it hasn't cost me anything to do it.
So that's one way in which I do.
Sometimes I spend my own money on it,
but I try not to for obvious kind of reasons.
Um,
and sometimes,
and I'm reasonably good at doing this,
I'll,
I'll create a solution which I think is potentially potent,
but doesn't necessarily have a huge budget attached to it.
So the examples that,
okay,
I'm not sure what point you came into the presentation,
my friend,
but the examples that I gave were all pretty low cost things that people seem to
enjoy.
So it doesn't need to cost the earth.
My worry,
and I easily could have,
I think,
uh,
this is slightly lessons now because we're in an economically more uncertain
time because of Brexit,
et Cetera,
et cetera.
But there was a time a couple of years ago where it was quite easy to get,
you know,
let's say 200 grand or something,
a seed money from,
uh,
you know,
I'll,
I want to be tech investor.
The issue then becomes their business plan becomes your business plan.
And I didn't want the,
the management of minority investment investors a pain in the ass at the best of
times,
but I wasn't quite sure how to make money out of it.
And whether or not the way in which I thought I might ultimately make money was
going to be something that they enjoy it.
So I just thought,
I'm just going to retain 100% of the equity and just do it myself.
I don't know whether that was the right decision or not,
but that's what I've done.
Yeah.
Um,
so in this sort of world of fake news,
have you thought about,
um,
sort of guarding against becoming a propaganda machine?
I'm thinking about the,
the,
the Donald Trump thing is that it may,
if now that he knows that that happened where she probably didn't like very
much.
Yeah,
we lost too much.
We thick skin and,
but now that that's come out,
maybe now people will start to look at your platform and take it much more
seriously and then sort of tried to battle against it.
So how,
how have you thought about how you might,
well,
I,
I mean my response is maybe a tiny bit in terms of what I've done so far might
be inadequate.
I'd be happy to concede that it has been.
What I've done is to,
uh,
when I write up what I generally do is like post the photo with the thing and
then do a couple of hundred words of copy a,
sometimes a bit less.
And I'm at pains to point out though we don't have a kind of political dog in
the fight,
et Cetera,
et cetera.
Just to stress the neutrality of the platform.
And what I've also found,
so in,
in,
uh,
the case of UK politics,
um,
I have done so did that Corbyn was slightly sarcastic attack on the leader of
the opposition.
I suppose attack is too strong a word,
but you know what I mean,
a bit of a death.
Uh,
I did a Ed Miliband thing where people wish that their,
uh,
MP spent more time in the constituency that that ostensibly meant to represent.
So I an Admin,
a band,
a,
a map of his constituency in North York show where he apparently was very
infrequently seen a,
I've done a bunch of David Cameron things.
I did a thing,
uh,
once,
with another politician whereby it was a,
it was a kind of trade thing basically where he wasn't doing enough for free
trade,
so I send,
let it bananas,
et Cetera,
et cetera.
So if I was to evaluate it,
everyone has been kind of no,
as I say that anyone's losing any sleep over it.
But everyone's been tarred with the same brush in that to the new standards,
I'm sorry.
And if they're starting to see that that's something will happen.
If a wish with them attached to it starts becoming a thing that they might start
going right this way.
Chabad,
you know,
Donald Trump being shown for who he is actually needs to be stopped and then
they tried to stop it from becoming the wish of the day
and then another sort of,
yeah,
I guess you'd have to,
it's a big number.
The stars that I've taken so far,
and as I say,
it's the same.
If sufficient number of people feel that this is something they want to see
happen.
I'm not a political person,
but I will make your wish naked Trump statute,
whatever.
I will make it kind of manifest,
but in so whilst doing that,
I'm going to stress that personally I don't have an opinion about Donald Trump.
We're just a service that brings things to life that otherwise,
as I say would remain tweets or whatever.
If we have time for maybe one or two more questions.
There's one here.
Hi.
What's your trickiest wish been to manifest if you had one that's ever really
stumped you?
Well,
a little bit because I suppose the,
I have a bit of a get out because I'm not,
like I said at the site,
I'm not guaranteeing to kind of make this soft come true.
I'm just a tiny gesture.
So generally I only sent out to do something that I know I can achieve by six
o'clock.
And I learned the hard way,
uh,
early on where I would find myself,
you know,
thinking about what the train times we're down to Kent so I could do some prank
on Nigel Farrage or something.
And then I think she,
I just haven't got time to do this.
I'm going to have to give them a downloadable poster or something instead.
So generally I don't,
um,
I don't come on stop that often.
I haven't missed one yet.
But definitely some of them are uh,
more testing than others.
And I'll think to myself,
okay,
what am I actually going to do here?
And typically those are the more conventional wishes where someone will say,
I wish my son is really ill and he just wants to go to Disneyland and could
because one thinks about wishes in that kind of sentence.
I think.
Cause you've seen that on TV programs,
what you've read about it on the press or you saw something go fund me that went
really well or whatever.
So quite often those ones,
those are the times when I feel like I'm disappointing people or bed cause I
will help them with that.
I'll publicize their campaign,
I'll tell the story and I'll amplify it to the people who follow me on social
media or whatever,
all of which is kind of positive.
But as a part of me that's thinking when they put that wish on the side,
they thought they were going to get him tickets to Disneyland the next day.
So that's the kind of time where I think,
oh shit,
you know,
that's something that that may be going to find that a little bit underwhelming.
But although having said that,
no one's ever got in touch with me and said,
oh my God,
that was so lame when you did that thing.
I hate you and might have thought it.
Okay.
I'm interested to know your thought process around how you keep control of the
actions and whether or not you've considered sort of outsourcing to the,
the people on the site.
It was when you said about there the old people home,
like if you could just with the users you could a scout that so everyone did.
But then where as we went through the three,
the presentation,
I was like,
Ooh,
no,
you probably want to keep control.
Yeah,
you still are.
I've got someone I know a little bit,
I don't know very well,
but we've had coffee a couple of times,
has got a site which were lies on peer to peer wish fulfillment.
So I go on there and I say,
ah,
I live in Shepherd's Bush and I'm having problems with my boiler.
Both of those facts are actually true cause that,
and then someone else says,
I will totally help you with your boiler.
And I said all that.
It's great.
We've made this fantastic craigslist style connection.
But simultaneously I'm mindful of the several serial killers who have stalked a
Craig's list.
And so I'm thinking there's a vulnerable woman who lives on her own.
She doesn't know what to do with that boy,
that she hasn't got the cash that it necessitates to get Pimlico plumbers out,
which is in my experience,
many hundreds of pounds.
And so this guy is going to,
who I have effectively brokered an introduction to is going to manifest on her
doorstep.
I don't know that fucking guy is.
He could be absolutely anyone.
And so that's one of the reasons I'm,
that kind of stuff.
Uh,
aside from how hideous some kind of incident would be of that nature obviously,
but not sure it can killer platform in seconds right there.
You know,
I'm,
I'm amazed that airbnb have come back so many times from people trashing
apartments in New York and having amphetamine fueled gay orgies and all this
kind of crazy stuff that's happened.
There are many,
many occasions and in fairness to Brian Chesky and card,
they've always managed that in quite a bit.
Well,
but I didn't want to be dealing with that and so I thought that if I'm in charge
of it,
that works better and it be risks it and editorially I can sign off my own kind
of idea,
which implementational terms just makes it way simpler.
It's like working for an ad agency and pitching an idea to the client and then
going to sit in the client's Jen and say,
yeah,
I buy your idea.
It makes it much,
much easier cause I got to do something every day.
Um,
there are however occasions where if it's publicising someone's fundraising idea
or a little boy wants to let a birthday cards or whatever,
I just said,
look,
send me all the birthday cards.
I'll package them up into a single pass or which makes more sense,
easier domestic cost of a stamp,
Robin International.
And I'll send them all and that works really,
really well.
Or people will get in touch with directly.
And again it says on the side,
if you think you can help out,
then email me and then I can slightly vet that person.
So they'll say,
well,
I'm brilliant.
Uh,
uh,
you know,
I'm great at public speaking or helping people overcome confidence issues and
here's my credentials for that.
And then I can say,
okay,
let's meet and have a cup of coffee.
And I've met loads and loads of people because very frequently the wishes
relates to a career dilemmas and so on.
So it's just a little,
come in,
we'll have a conversation and we'll be,
and that's invaluable kind of feedback to get cause,
oh well how'd you find out about the site?
Blah,
blah,
blah.
But 98% of the time I retain that control myself just because,
as I say,
it would terrify me to broker,
to strangers,
uh,
introduced them to each other.
That could be weird.
Is that it?
Is it time up?
It's half past one.
You need to get back guys.
Thank you very much for listening.